*sound releasing*
I love that every time. I love that. Hey what's up my friends it is summertime so for this video
I thought it might be fun to try experimenting with water balloons. Now for this project
I stopped by Walmart and picked up a pack of bunch of balloons
You're about seven and a half dollars they claimed to be able to fill up a hundred water balloons in 60 seconds
I don't think that technically true unless you have like three different hoses and three different bundles going at the same time however,
It's still very quick and very convenient so here's the idea guys when we put water in a vacuum chamber in a previous experiment
We saw the water start to boil
This is a common fact we've also seen videos where people put balloons and vacuum chambers and we watch them expand
So we know what water does in the vacuum chamber we also know what balloons do in a vacuum chamber
But what do water balloons do in a vacuum chamber? That's the question we're here to answer now to make this experiment work today
I'm bringing back the vacuum Chamber. We made in a previous video
This is designed to suck all the air out of the container and to get our water balloons ready
We'll need to pop outside for a second so we can fill them up with the garden hose. Let's go
Ok i'm outside, you can see I've got the garden hose hooked up to the blue bunch of balloons here
We're just going to turn the water on let these things fill up
I guess about half way full and then drop them into a container of water just to protect them then I'm going to do the
Red and the yellow for variety then we're going to go back inside
*Water balloon dropping in water*
All right back inside guys. We got our bunch of balloons filled up a lot of variety here
We got our yellow blue and our red
So I'm just going to take a few of these transfer them over into our cookie jar vacuum chamber
And then replace the lid and we'll fire this thing up and see what happens
[Music]
Let's start with that and call it good
Quick update guys, we're back
I got all the balloons filled up
And we've transferred enough of them in here to fill this jar halfway full so at this point
All we have to do is take our lid
Replace it on the top and basically turn on the vacuum chamber and see what happens. how are water balloon is going to react in
The vacuum chamber, let me know your guess in the comments below, and let's see if you're right. here we go. let's See what happens
[Music]
Okay, we're just going to close this valve here and turn off the vacuum pump for a second and talk about what we just saw
Now what's really interesting about this is we definitely see air bubbles collecting on the side of the water balloons
But they're not rapidly boiling like you would expect to see in a glass or a bottle of water
They're just kind of hanging out and all the water down here that's boiling,
I'm not sure if it's the water itself that's boiling, or if it's just gas escaping from these balloons
themselves. These little O-rings on the next to the bottle are great for holding in the water
But I'm not sure they're strong enough to actually prevent the air from coming out so let's go ahead and try opening up this vacuum
Chamber very quickly to see if there's any kind of a dramatic difference, and then I've got one more modification
I want to try making with them
*Air releasing*
Yeah, so did see the balloon shrink down a little bit so that definitely means that there was air
That was being expanded, but I'm thinking you know these shrink down more than normal size
These were some of the balloons that we started off with these are the balloons that we ended up with I don't really notice
Too much of a difference. It's kind of hard to tell. For round two,
I think what I'm going to do is actually physically tie off the next of these balloons. So that no air can escape
We'll see if that makes any difference because mostly balloons right now
don't really have any air in them so it will be interesting to see what happened under vacuum
[music]
It's a little Runt
All right, so we got one layer of balloons here. That's all I really had left
I tied these manually so there's no air that can escape
So when we throw the lid on and secure the valve this time is it going to make any difference?
Here we go
[Music]
All right, it's sucking
Looking at the water balloons themselves. You can see air bubbles forming on the inside
Now a lot of these didn't have much air in them to begin with, but you can see
Any air that was there is starting to expand and because they're manually tied off
I'm interested to see whether the water will start boiling inside the water balloon itself
There's no place for the pressure to leach out like it was in the first batch.
So I really really want to see water boiling inside of a water balloon. That's my goal. That's what I'm going for
[Music]
Now if I tip this forward you can see if there is a bit of water in there
And I do see from time to time little bubbles in the water like it is starting to boil
What I love is around the next to some of these balloons the air that was trapped in there bubbling up
making a little deformity
So I'll pop that with a pin
If anything you can see the tops of these water balloons where the air is is expanding even further
You give them a nice like easter egg looking shape all those dots around the edges makes it look pretty
But other than that, there is really nothing happening. Just going to let that sit for about five minutes then
[Music]
Guys we have had this running for 10 minutes solid, no joke, and I really haven't seen much difference
We shake them around the bubbles just kind of dissipate, but that's really about it
Alright, let's open this batch up and see if there's any difference
I love that, every time I love that. so the balloon shrinks down. I'm a little bit disappointed I didn't
see these boiling I mean
I was really really hoping to see the water start boiling in the balloon expanding to the point where they all
exploded, but that didn't happen
They just kind of hung out. Even with them tied off at the necks
But now you know if you were ever up late at night wondering What water balloons did in space?
I think the question is successfully been answered they don't really do much.
Thanks for joining me for this experiment. It is always an adventure,
and I'll be looking forward to the next video. Talk to you then
There we go nailed it
These are like the kind of juggling balls. You don't want to drop indoors
Subtitles by Nisha Hussain
like that
Follow on Twitter, Instagram, facebook and Google +. Subscribe for new content. Check out other videos. Subtitles by Nisha Hussain